brian it hurts just to think how fast he
was going at that point of impact wow
all right golden knights up back on the
ice tonight they're still in st louis
though for one more game before coming
home right chris
that's right one more there how the i'll
tell you what it's going to be
interesting to see what happens on the
road tonight before returning home to
play the coyotes on friday and sunday at
the fortress because the knights right
now
have a team that's kind of gotten beat
up here boy the knights really took it
to him on monday
the blues continue their nosedives
they've lost seven in a row and eight in
a row
at home the last time st louis won a
game was on march 20th
and remember these nhl teams are playing
every other day st louis hasn't won at
home since february 18th
vegas has now won four straight over the
blues and that's what has vegas
concerned because tonight the knights
know they'll get the blues best shot
you know we know this is going to be a
tough game and
you know as nice a win as that was and
as nice as
it was to score six goals i think we we
know we have to be better
particularly early in the game than we
were last game
all right we'll see if the knights do
what worked in monday's game that was
having bodies near the net vegas scored
two
in the first four more in the second for
that six to one win
on monday hey they face off at six
o'clock and we'll have highlights for
you this one tonight
at 11 o'clock denise